North Korean state media on Monday...
...lauded the spontaneous meeting between Kim Jong Un and US President Donald Trump...
...at the Demilitarized Zone dividing the two Koreas.
"The top leaders of North Korea and the United States...
...agreed to keep in close touch in the future, too,...
...and resume and push forward productive dialogue for achieving a new breakthrough...
...in the denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula and in bilateral relations."
Just a day before, President Trump shook hands with the North Korean dictator...
...before crossing the border,...
Stepping across that line was a great honor.
...making him the first sitting American president to set foot on North Korean soil.